all it took was one erroneous letter to
M was seemed like a legendary Jeopardy
Championship run in the making some fans
think Ben Chan got a raw deal there's a
reason Jeopardy has lasted as long as it
has plenty of viewers tune in to test
their own trivia knowledge others are
invested in the contestants and there's
no greater thrill than watching someone
win one episode after the next to get a
formidable streak going it's also tough
to watch an impressive streak end
especially when that loss comes with
controversy but that was the case for
the May 23rd 2023 episode featuring Ben
Chan a nine-day returning Champion he
wasn't the lead going into Final
Jeopardy but which the category was
Shakespeare's characters the clue was
both of the names of these two lovers in
a Shakespeare play come from Latin words
for blessed the other two contestants
incorrectly wrote Romeo and Juliet the
correct response was Beatrice and
Benedict from Much Ado About Nothing
Chan was largely correct but he
misspelled Benedict as Benedict
according to Jeopardy rules that was
enough to label his answer is incorrect
and he ended up losing the episode and
his winning streak unfortunately that is
not correct correct response Beatrice
and Benedict there have been plenty of
embarrassing flubs on Jeopardy over the
years and chance was relatively mild
compared to those it's obvious he knew
the answer even if he didn't know how to
spell Benedict numerous people took to
Twitter to express their disdain over
the ruling especially seeing how China's
obviously a smart guy who could have
gone far on the show one of you were
tweeted since when does being off by one
letter count in final Jeb as no other
character he could have meant many
people agreed in the comments and it
brings to light an important distinction
with Final Jeopardy throughout most of
Any Given game contestants have to say
their response out loud meaning it just
needs to sound correct Final Jeopardy
requires spelling which makes things
trickier another Twitter user argued the
ruling wasn't fair in light of another
contestant's response writing Lin
doesn't finish spelling Juliet yet his
rule is a complete albeit incorrect
response advance and Ben misspells
Benedict by one letter and is ruled
incorrect clearly they knew what he was
going for and yet and it has run on a
terrible technicality another claim that
sham would have been fine had it been a
regular clue the thing I hate about
Jeopardy as if Bennett said that
response he would have got it correct
but writing it was wrong the
inconsistency has always bugged me it
may indeed seem like splitting hairs to
say Benedict is too far from Benedict to
be accurate but Jeopardy seems to be
technically in the rights on this one on
the show's website there's a section on
spelling which states Jeopardy is not a
spelling test unless of course the
category requires a written responses to
the Final Jeopardy clue do not have to
be spelled correctly but they must be
phonetically correct and not add or
subtract any extraneous sounds or
syllables Benedict is pronounced
slightly differently than Benedict so
going by the guidelines Ben Chan's
answer should be labeled inaccurate and
he may have been ruled incorrect if he
said benedict with an audible T in a
regular clue as well on Reddit one of
you have thought the ruling was tough
but ultimately Fair writing
unfortunately as much as it looks harsh
it is the correct call I have to lean
with the judges on this one I just wish
host Mayim Bialik would have
demonstrated the difference of the two
names a bit more or explained why Ben's
answer is wrong like along the lines of
unfortunately the judges will not accept
it as it is pronounced differently or
exaggerate to the pronunciation slightly
it's a very memorable myth right so if
you're gonna go out on a Miss go out on
a memorable Miss based on the online
outrage it's obvious sham was a fun
favorite but at least he's not walking
away empty-handed his nine consecutive
victories earned him 252 600 in winnings
plus he'll have a chance to win even
more during the 2023 Tournament of
Champions